[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact a
tourist was finally rescued after being
stranded in Airport for more than a
hundred and ten days due to coronavirus
travel restrictions Roman Trofimov from
Estonia was travelling from Bangkok on
March 20 on Asia Airlines flight when he
landed at the Manila Airport in the
Philippines once he arrived however he
learned he would be unable to leave the
departure eras area as the Philippines
were not issuing arrival visas due to
coronavirus restrictions no exceptions
likewise Thailand would not allow him to
return because of the pandemic day after
day Roman a 36 year old software
engineer found himself trapped by red
tape in the departure zone of the
airport sleeping on the ground and
surviving on vending machine snacks and
food donated to him by sympathetic
airport staff the man made several
desperate pleas on social media to help
him get out of the airport
he said I'm personally a man with a
disability my health is getting worse
because of malnutrition lack of Sun and
fresh air he pled with his Estonian
embassy but they reportedly could not
get him a repatriation flight finally
The Times of Israel their Estonian
branch reached out to the foreign
ministry who agreed to return Roman
within hours he was on a plane back home
on July 7 after spending more than three
months living in the airport have you
ever felt like you are trapped in limbo
or yet worse purgatory you might be
surprised to learn what the Bible really
says about these spiritual waiting rooms
stay with us friends were going to learn
more on this edition of Bible answers
live you're listening to Bible answers
live accurate and practical answers to
your Bible questions hello friends
welcome to Bible answers live if you
have a Bible question we have lines open
a great time to pick up your phone and
give us a call we're not only available
by phone and that number eight hundred
four six three seven two ninety seven
but you can watch what's happening on
the Facebook pages that would be the
amazing facts Facebook page amazing
facts ministry or amazing facts
international and the Doug Batchelor
Facebook page once again if you want to
call in with a question a good time to
call with any question regarding the
Word of God the Bible or living the
Christian life that number 800 god says
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven and I am Doug Batchelor my
name is Jean Ross good evening friends
and pastor Doug let's start the program
with prayer dear father we thank you
that we have this opportunity once again
to open up your word and study together
and we ask your blessing upon this
program be with those who are listening
and we just pray that you guide us as we
study the Bible in Jesus name Amen amen
well pastor I don't know you've done
quite a bit of traveling and you've
probably spent quite a bit of time in
airports waiting for flights you know
even three hours in the airport can seem
long sometimes even eight hours I've had
to spend in an airport flight was
delayed but can you imagine spending
three months in the departure area of an
airport that to me is a sign of that
would be torment just I can't imagine
that I've had to like you walk around
the airports when it's all empty and
people are kind of a few people here and
they are sleeping in here it's you don't
have enough time to go to a hotel and
you don't have enough time to really get
comfortable and go to sleep and so you
just wander
around and it could be really depressing
and so I felt so sorry for this fellow
when I read that he was trapped there
that long I've been in the Manila
Airport as you probably have several
times and there's not a lot of
entertaining things that are happening
there
I think they ultimately gave him a
somewhat private spot where he and they
gave him a fan and you can see pictures
online where he's got just a blanket on
the concrete and just not very pleasant
caught in limbo and you know friends
maybe you've heard the term purgatory or
limbo and you've wondered you know is
there a waiting area when people die
where you could be trapped between
heaven and hell and what does the Bible
say about that well we've got a book
that I think is going to help you and
it's based on some scriptures people
often misunderstand it's one of those
famous passages known as the rich man
and Lazarus you can actually read the
story record it there in the Gospel of
Luke folks have wondered could this
maybe be some kind of purgatory that the
Bible speaking of well it's a very
important passage it's a parable that
Jesus told and it's got some important
lessons but it's not talking about
purgatory and we'd like to send this to
anyone who would call and ask the book
is called the rich man and Lazarus and
if you'd like to receive the book the
number to call for that is just our
resource phone line eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven again
that number is 885 six seven four seven
we will send the book anywhere in North
America and you'll be blessed by reading
it again it's called the rich man and
Lazarus call that number and ask for it
and we'll be happy to send it to you
we're gonna go to the phone lines we've
got our first caller this evening is
Chris listening in Florida Chris welcome
to the program hey Chris you're on the
air between the dogs that were
predestined meaning and and those who
the chosen ones well why do you think
I'm sorry but why do you think there's a
difference
because those that were our protested
were predestined some of them will end
up in heaven some of them in English
turn on fire it is correct didn't know I
don't think anybody has been predestined
by God to be created and burned the
Bible tells us that God is not willing
that any should perish God through his
Providence has provided means where
every believer can be saved that's why
he says whosoever will and so God did
not create people to be destroyed it's
the Lord doesn't want to see anyone
perish it says God who would have all
men be saved God is not willing that any
should perish and you know we we have a
book that talks about the predestination
we can send you and and so the you know
the chosen when God chose the children
of Israel they he wanted them to all
make it to the promised land but because
of their lack of faith they didn't then
you know first generation many didn't
but those who believed like Joshua and
Caleb they did and so we can choose to
believe but for example the chosen ones
even believers not everybody will end up
in heaven is it correct it's true that
not everybody that claims to be a
Christian will end up in heaven but
that's not because God has predetermined
that they should be destroyed I think
God wants everybody to be saved you know
God is love and nothing can separate us
from the love of God and you know when
the children of the Northern Kingdom
Ephraim when they turned away from God
God says how can I give you up he didn't
want them to be lost the Lord says
Turney and this is Ezekiel 18 I think
kearney Turney why will you die
yeah good God is pleading with the Lost
to trust him and to come to him he's not
wanting anyone to be lost and he hasn't
chosen that and he should be lost so
hope that helps go ahead yeah it's a
book that will give you on can a save
man she used to be lost if you'd like to
receive that Chris the number to call is
a time
eight three five six seven four seven
and after the book can I save man choose
to be lost again that number is 885 six
seven four seven of course this is not
only for Chris but for anyone who would
like to see the book call the number ask
for it we'll be happy to send it to you
we've got Jerry listening from Michigan
Jerry welcome to the program hello can
you hear me loud and clear great I live
off good and I don't get very good phone
reception so I hope you can hear me yeah
we hear you good okay my question is
this when Jesus was alone in the Garden
of Gethsemane praying to his father and
son and sweating drops of blood how did
the writers of the Bible know what
happened to him and what he was saying
when all the disciples were see yeah
well keep in mind that Jesus will two
things one they may have her overheard
cuz several times he woke him up and
they eventually drifted to sleep so um
you know Peter James and John he invited
them to go with him as he went deeper
into the garden he went a little further
beyond them but they may have heard him
praying cuz he was praying in agony and
probably loud and the other thing is
after Jesus rose from the dead he talked
to them on many occasions and he may
have you know rehearsed what happened
that night in the garden when he was
betrayed so you know and through divine
inspiration God can give a prophet a
vision of what happened that makes sense
Jerry
yes sir goes thanks very much
you're the strong tower angel is the
only station I get way up here in the
northern you pour Peninsula so I really
thank you for your program and for
answering my questions well praise the
Lord yeah we're good friends with strong
tower radio and I didn't know there was
a paradise Michigan we got a paradise
California - at least we did its Hill in
most of it birds right next quote that
we have these reason listening in North
Carolina recent welcome again to Bible
answers life
yeah out of the New King James I mean
it's probably the same in the King James
18 this these people started worshipping
[Music]
maybe the Messiah that was to come I
don't know but either way they decided
it looks like to me they were determined
to worship yeah just for our friends
that are listening when Moses was going
through the wilderness and Jesus refers
to this story in John chapter 3 the
people were bitten by serpents they had
been complaining about the manna that
God had given him and and the Lord
withdrew his protection and just a
plague of not only serpents these are
venomous serpents this began to swarm
out and this happens every now and then
in the spring they all hatch out at the
same time and many of the people were
bitten and they're dying and there's
just a whole plague thousands I think
we're dying and God told Moses to have
one of the artisans and the camp make a
bronze Serpent and put it on a staff a
pole and hold it up and it says whoever
looks will be healed of the venom now
this was a one-time event that was it
was to be a symbol teaching that if
people would look in faith to God that
he would destroy the power of the
serpent filled with meaning for the
Christian and let me just throw
something in here for you I've got a
book in the head you will send you a
free copy it's called the Savior and the
serpent and it talks about John 3:16 it
talks about Hezekiah during the time of
Hezekiah hundreds of years after Moses
more than a thousand years after Moses I
think the people had made an eye
this serpent that was still in the
sanctuary and they were praying to it
because they thought it had some special
power
and Hezekiah recognized that that was
never God's intention that they should
make an idol out of anything breaks one
of the second commandments and one of
the tens the second commandment and he
had it broken to pieces and called it I
think the Rushton which means a thing of
brass it's just a piece of brass and so
I don't know that the people understood
the significance of what it had been
symbolized in the time of Moses but
we'll send you that book called the
savior in the serpent we'll send you a
free copy reason her and I think he'll
be blessed by that the number to call is
883 five six seven four seven again that
is the resource phone line and the book
is called the savior and the serpent
will send it out to anyone who calls and
asks again 800 eight three five six
seven four seven
we've got Claudia listening from Miami
Florida
Claudia welcome to the program evening
still with us yeah and your question oh
my question was yeah you about the
pandemic I see that they put some oats
here we usually let people do it and
save their question too but it says that
you've got a question about the pandemic
does it have anything to do with Rome in
the kingdom of Spain - uh-huh but what
about the disgrace that we live in right
now I want to know what would be the
escape to not getting seeing when we
were about to be in more pandemics
hopefully no I don't know so in the
Bible work and I hold on to it yeah
there's that good question there first
of all Jesus did say that you know
there's gonna be pestilence in the last
days and this plague is certainly a sign
of this is certainly not one of the
worst pestilence that we've had I mean
we're not exactly seeing the Black Death
we're one out of three people died
neither are we seeing
they're terrible pandemic of the Spanish
influenza 1918 but and there will be
other plagues and plagues may not always
be a virus you know anything that can
bring kind of mass dying from disease is
a plague but there's a promise in Psalm
91 where it said that neither will any
plague come near your dwelling so I
would recommend you read the promises
that God has in Psalm 91 and I think
you'll find that very encouraging and
you know I was looking pastor Ross as we
were going through I was kind of
reorganizing some of the free offers
that amazing facts has and Joe Cruz has
a book that talks about when the brook
dries up that offers just you know some
encouragement during difficult times and
we'll be happy to send it to anyone who
would like some encouragement what is
the Bible like to say about difficult
times and it's called when the brook
dried up and again the number to call
for that is just our resource phone line
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and as for the book called
when the brook dried up eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
we've got Sarah actually Ethan rather
listening from Texas Ethan welcome to
the program hi hi Ethan how old are you
you're five one so thankful you called
what is your question tonight well you
know the Romans didn't especially they
didn't especially hate Jesus but they
were running the government and some of
Jesus enemies that were some of the
religious leaders they were jealous and
they said that Jesus was making himself
a king instead of Caesar and that he was
going to start a rebellion and and the
Roman governor Pontius Pilate he thought
to hell to satisfy the the Jews and to
prevent a rebellion he should go ahead
and execute Jesus and and even Jesus
said you know Judas and the priests who
delivered Jesus to the Romans had the
greater sin they were more guilty than
even the Romans in fact when
Jesus died on the cross one of the Roman
soldiers there by the cross looked at
Jesus and said surely this was the Son
of God
so we're gonna probably see some of them
in heaven
that's a great question thanks so much
Ethan does that help you're welcome
thank you for calling alright next call
that we have is a Rueben listening from
Oxnard California Ruben welcome to the
program hello my question is what is one
of the altar of the in I'm sorry or one
of the four horns of the altar of the
incense represent or symbolize yeah well
the number four in the Bible typically
represents something that is universal
you know Jesus said he'll send his
angels to the four corners of the earth
that means north south east and west and
then you look in Revelation I think it's
chapter 7 where it talks about four
angels are holding back the four winds
of strife so they do not blow upon the
earth that means it's something that
universal trouble well the four horns of
the altar mean that salvation of Jesus
sacrifice because the altar is where the
sacrifice was burnt is meant for all of
the world so we're getting can you hear
us Ruben we're getting a little
background noise yeah no yeah yes I can
hear well so does that help or make
sense
yes all right hey well thank you so much
for your call we sure appreciate it and
God bless you
next caller that we have is changing
listening in California ginger welcome
to the program hi hi thanks for calling
well my question is what is the
difference between having like having
faith and having presumption you know
what's the difference if I pray or five
you know and I have faith but is that
presumption that I know it's going to
happen well good
very good question ya know that's a good
question
you know if faith is going to be based
upon a promise of God and the the
definitive leading of the Spirit when a
person says you know I think I'm gonna
jump in front of a car and believe in
angels gonna save me
that's presumption you know when you
start tempting the Lord like when the
devil told Jesus jump off the temple and
the angels will catch you
that's presumption if you start spending
your money carelessly and say well I'm
just gonna have faith God's gonna give
me more money or help me win the lottery
that's presumption you know God wants us
to use common sense now faith is gonna
be you're gonna find a promise in the
Bible and they'll usually be some
criteria to connect with that promise
and and believe that as you follow those
criteria God is gonna honor you have
faith that he's gonna honor his word and
his promises you there yeah okay does
that make sense yes it does I wasn't
sure as I pray or if I you know
something will happen or I take God's
promises and my presuming that this will
happen or me or not I'll tell you what
I've got a book I'm gonna send you if
you call the resource line we don't give
this out to everybody but if you call
the resource line I've got a book called
who do you think you are and it's about
faith who do you think you are you call
and you can tell them I said I'd send
you a free copy of that and I think
that'll encourage you it's all about
faith then I'm gonna call for that he's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and again you can ask to the
book called who do you think you are
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven
Esther is listening California Esther
welcome to the program Esther you there
Esther might be on mute oh I think we
just lost this no we just had a cold up
there we have Deanna listening in Texas
Deanna welcome to the program hello
hi how are you good thank you for
calling um I do have a question it is I
have a grandson that's autistic and then
my husband has some problems - he's like
an anger disorder OCD some other
problems yes and does have a great heart
for God my husband does I mean he is
like you know I he just loves the Lord
with all his heart and wondering the if
people like them make their way into
heaven well the good news is God is a
loving God he's fair he's a just God and
God will never ask us to be or to do
something that is impossible for us to
be or to do without His grace if someone
has a mental handicap of some sort and
they can't you know they're doing all
they can humanly do with God's power to
to live the life but because of some
medical problem or a chemical problem
you know God's gonna judge them fairly
and so you know God will not expect a
person who was born with a severe mental
mental handicap to understand the gospel
the way someone else might Jesus said to
whom much is given much is required and
those who don't have much to work with
you know he's he's very gracious with
them so does that make sense yes thank
you very much okay hey god bless thank
you for calling Deana you know we do
have a book pass the bag entitled the
riches of His grace and it looks about
God's grace and His goodness and we'll
send it to anyone who calls a nasty Anna
you might want to call and ask for it
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven and again you can just ask for the
book called the riches of His grace and
we'll be happy to put that in the mail
and send it to anyone who calls and asks
we've got Jim listening in Indiana Jim
welcome to the program oh well welcome
you're on the air
I was just wondering the two witnesses
in Chapter 11 and revelations uh-huh
are they to be taken literally I mean no
I'm giving you the short answer but I'll
give you more detail when it talks about
these two witnesses that are going to be
killed and their bodies will lie in the
street and and after three days some
people think that Moses and Elijah are
going to come down from heaven
you know they now have eternal life
their glorified bodies that they're
going to be killed and their mutilated
bodies will lay in the street for three
days and then they're going to be
resurrected the revelation is full of
symbols and these two witnesses are
symbolized by Moses and Elijah they are
the law and the prophets the Word of God
the new in the Old Testament and you
know the law is written on two stones
the Bible is called a sword with two
edges there's a dual nature there to the
Word of God so these are the two
witnesses that during a unique time in
history and I'm wondering what book are
lesson we have that talks about that you
know we have a book called the to
witness oh yeah which goes into this
passage in a lot more detail and we'll
be happy to send this to to you Jim or
anyone who would like to learn more
about Revelation chapter 11 what does it
say about the two witnesses the number
to call is eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven again 800
eight three five six seven four seven
you can answer the book called the two
witnesses and we'll be happy to send
that to anyone it's just a really
important fascinating study a lot of
good information talking about Moses and
Elijah you know some people pastor that
might be surprised too if they get the
book they might be surprised to hear
that not only did Elijah go to heaven we
know Elijah waned without seeing yet but
Moses was resurrected and taken to
heaven and he appears with Jesus and the
Mount of Transfiguration that you can
read about as well so all of that's in
the book all of the Bible verses are
there and you know whoever gets it I
think you'll enjoy reading it yes sir so
hope that helps a little bit you know
just before we go to the break pastor
Ross or something we would like to
mention we are coming into yes friends
another election season and there's a
lot
going on in the in the world and the
country everything from the gyrating
economy to the surging off and on of the
pandemic and various freedoms they go
along with that and there's a lot of
social unrest and we're in the middle of
a very polarizing election season and
people sometimes call and say pastor
Doug you know what does the Bible say
about Christians and voting is it a lack
of faith to vote is it required that you
vote are there some scriptures on this
and you know we just thought it was
important to give a little bit little
perspective because in North America
once every two years there's some kind
of election presidential election every
four years and some kind of
congressional elections every couple of
years so we have a book that we would
like to send you friends it's called
should a Christian vote should a
Christian vote if you'd like and this is
if you want a single copy we'll send it
to you for free if you want something to
share then you can get more information
by calling the amazing facts office but
we think you'll find this a balanced
perspective and it will be a blessing
and so just you can contact the amazing
facts website for that you hear the
music we have more questions coming got
room for you to call in with your
questions we'll be back in just a few
moments
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy study Bible stance apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future
what would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named Rahm was violent they were
ruthless
they were determined the Gospel writers
seek his death as a fulfillment of
salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273 72 97 and once again we
are streaming on the amazing facts
Facebook page my name is Doug Batchelor
my name is John Ross and before the
break we were gonna hear from esta St in
California yes so welcome to the program
can you hear me loud and clear oh good
um I have a silly question I've been
wanting to do some home repairs but
seeing how we're living in these times
now and even some store is not accepting
cash anymore should I continue with my
projects or just just let it go well you
know that's a great question
jesus said and pastor Ross might look it
up for me where he said occupy till I
come Jesus and one of his parables about
distributing the talents to his
disciples he told them to occupy till he
comes meaning that if you need to buy
sell trade since we don't know the day
or the hour of his coming I think every
Christian needs to live like this could
be our last day when it comes to our
spiritual health but I think we need to
work and plan like we might be here a
thousand years when it comes to thinking
ahead so I would say you know if you've
got the means and if just suppose that
you were gonna be here another 20 years
would you do the improvements
a lot of people during World War one
thought this was the end of the world
and they just let their houses fall
apart and after the word they said maybe
we better fix them you know the parable
I think you're referring to
I'm looking at the new King James that
woods a little different it says that do
business till I come right Luke chapter
19 verse 13 so I think God wants us to
be wise stewards if we can do something
to increase the value of our property
it's probably good to do so the Lord
might call us at some point to liquidate
what we have and maybe put it more into
evangelism or gospel preaching but until
you know God guides us we should be wise
stewards yep
yeah I don't know that I'd get involved
in some ornate repairs but does that
help Esther
it sure does it put my heart at ease
because I was so completed thank you so
much alrighty god bless I hope we gave
you the right advice
we've got Virginia listening Kentucky
Virginia welcome to the program hello hi
Virginia you're on the air
hi pastor how are you good how are you
good I have a question what is gonna be
the outcome of those individuals who
committed suicide you know I don't think
there's one answer for that because I do
think that there are varying
circumstances now what I mean by that is
I do think in most cases not in all
cases but in many cases what a person
commits suicide they have reached a
state of hopelessness and often that's
connected with faithlessness and without
faith it's impossible to please God
again I want to mention that some people
get just tired of life they're tired of
suffering and they say you know I'm just
gonna end it all but you know we're
we're made in God's image we're God's
property and killing murder is a sin and
that would include self murder now
having said that and the reason I I have
to answer this question with two
perspectives we get calls every now and
then from some young person that's
discouraged and they want to know can I
kill myself and go to heaven they're
thinking of killing themselves I say
absolutely don't because if you could
think that you're gonna kill yourself
and you're gonna make your life easier
in most cases when people commit suicide
their next conscious thought is being
raised in a permanently bad situation
there is no more hope but when you're
alive the Bible says where there is life
there is hope a living dog is better
than a dead lion but having said all
that then there are some people who have
a loved one instead of committed suicide
and they're going is there any hope that
they might be saved well yes there is
God looks on the heart and there are
some people who maybe they were going
through severe pain pastor Ross and I
had a member of that godly person but
they went through some disease where
they just were not thinking clearly and
they nearly tried to kill themselves and
then they realize later what had
happened but they weren't in the right
mind and they were in so much pain and
God will judge a person not on the last
moment of their lives but the tenor of
their life some people may try to kill
themselves and then they repent of it
before they actually die and you know
God is merciful so we've got to be very
careful about judging even Samson he
knew very well when he pushed down the
building he was gonna die he said his
last words were let me die with the
Philistines and so but Samson's gonna be
in heaven because it was a little more
like a sacrifice than a suicide so I
don't know if this is helping Virginia
but I saw it varies with every
individual does that make sense
so we cannot say that if a person
committed suicide they're not gonna go
to him and we can't say that I think
we've got to be careful not to say it as
an absolute I think in I think in most
cases as I said it indicates you know
this week some policemen quarter a
murderer sorry shot himself yeah I don't
think there's a lot of hope for people
in those circumstances but some people
you don't know it could be miserable
illness and we've got to be careful not
to judge hey thanks so much we need to
do a little sermon book on that because
we get that question a lot do we've got
sadly listening in illinois sally
welcome to the program oh hi sally and
how can we help you tonight what's your
question
Prison Jail Mexico and I thought you
know how I'll be able to pray for you
well that's a great that's a great
question because the good news is you
may not be able to be with her if you
can visit good if you can write a letter
good but God is with this person and you
know there's a lot of people that get
converted in in jail pastor Doug was not
always a Christian I was in jail seven
different times not visiting people so I
know it can get pretty lonely and you're
really thankful if someone comes to
visit so pray that God will bring her
comfort because God can send angels to
be with your friend and to comfort them
and write write a note they'll let the
mail go through usually and hold them up
before the Lord and then tell them
you're praying for so does that help
Sally thank you okay thank you for your
call and you know some prisons will let
you bring in Christian literature so you
might send or bring in something for
them to read because you get really
mm-hmm I know a lot of people who have
read their way to Jesus well in jail
alright next full of the behalf Thank
You Sally we've got Michael listening in
Michigan Michael welcome to the program
yeah thank you for taking my call my
question is this in the Old Testament in
the book of Joshua after the defeat of
AI the Lord tells Joshua that he will no
longer be with Israel unless he seeks
out this accursed thing and moves it
from the camp of course they cast lots
and it lands on Aiken and he confesses
his sin so my question is why were his
sons and daughters included in the death
sentence his punishment and what is the
implication of that for our churches
today how we handle sin in the church
yeah a very good question you know
there's it's not explicitly stated but
it's understood by most scholars that he
hid the gold in the garment the
Babylonian garment and the silver he hid
it under a carpet in his tent and that
his family were accomplice as to what he
had done the family had heard the very
clear command of Joshua of
Lord not to take any of the spoils of
Jericho it was all to be consecrated to
God
so he'd not only stolen but he'd stolen
from God and his family was privy to it
and so he actually he engendered the
guilt in his whole family and they were
all punished his whole household that
was aware of it was punished that
doesn't mean he had little children but
that's what I have understand and you
know you wonder if he waited until he's
actually caught yeah he wasn't repenting
his sorry
he's been because he was busted if you
would have come forward earlier than
that and said you know I'm sorry I made
a mistake here it is but he waited till
the very last repented like Judas when
he went out and hung himself was a
little too late yeah all right well my
co
we've got Thomas listening Arizona
Thomas welcome to the program i pastored
Doug how are you doing doing well we
like studying the Bible and you're
questioning me I was I was discussing
with a friend the other day the book of
Zechariah and chapter 13 and
particularly verses 6 ok my friend seems
to be under the impression that this is
talking about Jesus and believes that
this is indicating that Jesus is
actually not the Messiah or is a false
prophet I don't necessarily agree with
that but I would really appreciate your
interpretations of what this means all
right well let me read the verse for our
friends that are listening and I'm gonna
start with verse so 4 and this is a
Cariah 13 verse 4 and it shall be in
that day that every prophet will be
ashamed of his vision when he prophesies
and they'll not wear a robe of coarse
hair to deceive you keep in mind Elijah
like John the Baptist they were camel
skin and it was kind of typical of some
of the prophets back then but he'll say
I am no prophet I am a farmer for a man
taught me to keep cattle from my youth
and one will say to him what are these
wounds between your arms and I'll answer
those with which I was wounded in the
house of my friends and the word between
your arms there also means hands and as
you can say these are the wounds I
received in the house of my friend
and Jesus is he of course a prime
example he is a prophet and he was
wounded by his own people and betrayed
by one of his own apostles so most
scholars I don't know of any that don't
believe that this is a prophecy a very
clear messianic prophecy and I think
even if you read the next verse verse
seven makes it even clearer it says
awake o sword against my shepherd
against the man who is my companion says
the Lord of hosts strike the Shepherd
and the sheep will be scattered and of
course that was a reference that Jesus
made he actually quoted this verse when
talking to his disciples in the upper
room there before his betrayal so even
Jesus likened this verse the fulfillment
of this verse to himself yeah he quotes
this in Matthew 26 31 also so Christ
Himself points back to Zechariah and
he's a pretty good bible expositor so I
would think that that's a good evidence
this is a prophecy about what happened
to Christ now your friend thinks that
this is proof that Jesus is a false
messiah yes sir because the wording
prior to that seems to be indicating
something about you know indicating at
the process the Prophet would be a liar
because it says you shall not live
because you've spoken lies in the name
of the Lord that's referencing verse 3
well I think that yeah I think that the
the subject matter and the the person
being addressed is changing even in the
passage Zechariah is talking about true
and false prophets all through no
clutter and you'll you'll find that some
of these apocalyptic prophets like
Zechariah and Ezekiel even Revelation it
very quickly jumps from subject to
subject isaiah does that isaiah starts
out prophesying about the king of tyre
and then in 1 verse he jumps over and
talks about the devil who is behind the
king of tyre so I hope that helps a
little Thomas and you know if you look
in even online you look at some of the
Bible commentators on this
these great Protestant commentators
they've got great explanations on these
things but I think almost all of them
agree this is a messianic prophecy all
right next we'll have it be heavies jack
listening from Las Vegas Jack welcome to
the program praise the Lord this is
awesome thank you guys for taking my
call thank you so much thank you
Russian tonight um well just real quick
pastor Doug I've been listening to you
on amazing fact just a quick testimony
I've been I was a gosh I was a drunk
homeless the worst worst person you
could possibly imagine I happened upon
amazing facts one Sunday morning four
years ago you've changed my life in so
much that I'm ministering now to people
and so I've been really enthused about
this new quarterly about witnessing I've
been watching all of the sermons and I'm
really enthused so my question is I'm
I'm ministering to a gentleman right now
and this is pretty much yes I won't call
it a road block because I feel like I
have a pretty good way of getting around
it but I'm not getting around it but I
preach Daniel 2 because I bought the
teaching tool the the statue of
Nebuchadnezzar which by the way is
amazing yeah I love it and everybody is
always struck by it then I preach Daniel
9 because I think it's important to know
why Jesus is our Messiah right uh-huh
what's the next step what's the next
slam-dunk where can I go next because
they're always excited about Daniel 9
you know what you were and I am I go
what do I go next well I can't speak
pastor Ross might have an idea but I
would if you haven't done it yet and
you're talking about the the coming of
the Lord go to Matthew 24 and continue
the theme that because Matthew 24 gives
you more detail about even the days
we're living in now gospel getting into
all the world and then the end will come
yes okay yeah that's all in there so
what I guess suppose next yeah I agree
my 24 right great I am going to just so
you guys know I'm in the process of
signing up for Africa I'm so enthused
about spreading your guyses message and
I'm going to sign up for the programs
and I'm very very excited about
and I just want you guys to know that
you've changed my life and it's it's
really touching to think that the
thoughts that I used to think and the
things that I think now it's just
Lourdes giving you knew her edible hey
man yeah sure
well that's why we do it jack we sure
appreciate your testimony tonight and
for our friends who are listening you
might be wondering what Jack's talking
about Affco afro is the amazing fact
center of evangelism we do teaching
right now it's all online
but we've actually been doing online for
several years so it wasn't just because
of the pandemic but we teach principles
of soul winning Bible study witnessing
so people can do mission work evangelism
Bible work and it's a very popular
program you can just go to Africa dot
o-r-g or calm or be the one on both will
get you there or you go to the amazing
facts website click on the tab that says
training and you can take a look at what
the different courses are if you'd like
to study more during the pandemic we're
actually offering a special we're kind
of doing our wanted to get people in it
that's right we've got a great group of
students that are actually going through
the program a FC o e.com thanks for coal
jack next call at the behalf let's see
we've got Michael listening in Wisconsin
Michael welcome to the program hello hi
thank you guys for having me on I my
question is how do you like because I've
talked to a lot of people about you know
you know myspace from you know not just
different Christian backgrounds from you
know different backgrounds you know
outside of Christianity and when you're
looking at people who believe in like
different gods you know who you know
come from you know backgrounds of faith
that are that are you know with the
Bible and things like that like how do
you show people or tell people because I
want to tell people you know that that
Jesus is the real da the true God how do
you show someone who you know believes
in another God that our God is you know
the one true God good question you know
and that every I think every Christian
needs to have an answer for that
question
when you're witnessing to people that
aren't Christians about the truth in the
Word of God how do you approach them you
know suppose they come from a Muslim
background or Buddhist or Hindu
background and and you know that for
them the Bible they don't know the Bible
well how you gonna reach them you know
one of the first things you need to do
is establish faith in the Bible and if
you can prove to them that the Bible is
a supernatural book in the way that it
it has prophecies that were written very
specific prophecies written hundreds if
not thousands of years before the event
occurs and then this very specific event
occurs people are going to begin to
recognize Wow this by this book is
extraordinary it's not normal and Jesus
said the words I speak or spirit in life
and as they develop confidence in the
Bible if you can have a little time to
show them some of these scriptures then
there are faith in everything else the
Bible says is built and you can then
give them Studies on other principles
and who Jesus is now amazing facts just
completed a DVD that talks about how you
can know the Bible is true it has about
39 or 40 prophecies that prove the Bible
is true and it's called kingdoms in time
in fact anyone out there you can you can
go to the kingdoms and time website or
you can go to even I think it's on
Amazon Prime is now here we're really
excited that Amazon picked up a movie we
produced Amazon Prime it's on the pure
flicks the Christian movie Network
they're carrying it but that'd be a
great way to get those prophecies and I
think we just produced the magazine
mm-hmm just coming out so again it's a
good question I think as pastor Doug
mentioned but the starting point is to
help them recognize that the Bible is
unique book and it's unique in that it's
inspired by God it can reveal prophecy
it can reveal the future and that's it's
the Bible apart from all other religious
books or other writings so let it be a
good starting point thanks to Col
Michael next hope that we have is Renato
listening in California we're not are
welcome to the program oh thank you
thanks for calling
oh this is my pleasure pastor yeah
so my question has to raise about the
Genesis creation yes and after the flood
it's kind of since Adam and Eve said in
the Bible if you are the first couple so
obviously there's like like a marriage
within the family yes yeah that's true
mm-hmm so what nowadays we call that
infant right so why if why was it wrong
why is it wrong now for marrying your
your sister or your stepsister anyone
that's a close relative but it was okay
back in the beginning now think about it
when God made Adam and Eve technically
they have the same parents God and so
Adam married his sister matter of fact
it's even weirder than that she came
from his side and then Cain and Abel and
and Seth never says Abel married I don't
know if you live long enough but Seth
and Cain they married their sisters by
the time you get to Abraham he married
his half-sister and then by the time you
get to Jacob he married his first cousin
Isaac married his first cousin and by
the time of Moses they realized you know
if you continue to intermarry you can
have genetic problems and that was the
main reason God said do not look upon
the nakedness of your sister and they
were not to marry within the family
so even probably before the time of
Moses they realized that this it was
healthier to have a strong gene pool and
you know they were a nation of shepherds
they understood how breeding worked if
if you've read too much in the same same
group you end up with genetic weaknesses
and and so when man was perfect as God
made him that wasn't so much of a
problem and although but as time went by
it was we have time for maybe one more
question pastor Oz yeah we got Lawrence
listening in Illinois Lawrence welcome
to the program thank you yeah
and your question my question is uh when
her Jesus was talking with his disciples
before he went to die for us on the
cross he was transfigured in front of
his apostles and during that whenever he
was transfigured it talks about Moses
and Elijah was seen next to him mm-hmm
how did the Apostles no but that was
Moses and Elijah without actually ever
meeting or singing them yeah a good
question if they never have seen any
pictures or video how they know it was
Moses and Elijah when you read the story
in mark it says they appeared when you
read it in Luke it says they appeared
and they spoke with him and so we can
assume that Jesus addressed them by name
and they understood and also you know
when you're in a heavenly vision like
that God gives you supernatural
discernment because you're just
surrounded by the Holy Spirit and angels
and God Himself spoke to them and yeah
they Moses and Elijah were speaking with
him concerning his sacrifice he would
accomplish you know I've got a book I'll
be happy to send you know we mentioned
earlier tonight and it's called the
glorious mount or the two witnesses and
we'll be happy to send you a free copy
it's all about that story the number to
call for that is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and
again just ask - the book called the two
witnesses will be happy to send that to
anyone who calls and asks one more
question real quick all right we've got
let's say we've got Ally's listening
from San Bernardino California ally
welcome to the program hi good evening
you mean yes my question is there a way
that you can explain Trinity in the
simple way to a person with Adam video
and saying that there's one God even if
it's Trinity
I'll try first I want to tell you that
we'll send you a book on it and it's
called a one God or three understanding
the Trinity secondly try to depending on
their level of understanding you might
explain that you can have one family now
in the one bachelor family right
now in the house because our son came
home from college
we've got father mother's son and so
there's three of us we are the bachelor
family think of God not as a term that
would describe a one person see Jesus
said a man leaves his father and mother
Cleaves to his wife and he and his wife
become one so in the Hebrew mind one
wasn't always talking about numerical
numbers it was talking about unity a man
and woman become one jesus said to the
Apostles in John 17 he said father I
pray they may be one as you and I are
one well there were twelve apostles but
he wanted them to be United God the
Father Son and Holy Spirit are one Moses
said here o Israel the Lord our God is
one God the other nations worship gods
that were always fighting and bickering
among themselves but the Israelites have
a perfectly United God in the beginning
God said let us make man in our image so
the plural nature of God is seen right
there in the first book of the Bible and
it's seen all the way at the end where
it says the spirit and the bride say
come
and ask for that book on the Trinity if
you'd like to receive at the number two
Col deze 808 three five six seven four
seven and again the book is just called
the Trinity one god of three and we'd be
happy to send that out to anyone who
calls and asks well friends we just want
to remind you that these programs after
we broadcast them they are archived on
the amazing facts Facebook page if you
have enjoyed it learned anything new
send the link to your friends you'll see
it also on the Doug Batchelor Facebook
page and to keep us in your prayers
remember we are faith ministry if you've
been blessed you can go to amazing facts
com there's a little button called
donate and that really means we love you
we appreciate hearing from you god bless
Alexia
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California what if you could
know the future
what would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by Pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com if you enjoy
hearing solid biblical answers on Bible
answers live you can have those same
insights at your fingertips through the
amazing facts prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols charts and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
538 7275 for life changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore com
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF ax0 RG and sign
up for our free Bible study course and
make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 may sing facts 0 RG